Brothers and sisters, imagine for a
second that you give 10 pounds in
donation and that 10 pounds is used to
buy food [music] or bricks or whatever
to help the people in Gaza. But then
just imagine this amazing deed that you
want to do, but we turn it into a
money-making machine. How?
The waqf [music] is exactly that. They
take your money and the money that we
are going to put in in this waqf, this
building, and every [music] single time
the money generated from that waqf, that
building, is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next [music] 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 100,
150 years. And this will be a form of
true sadaqah jariyah. I myself will be
donating for that, inshallah. Click the
link below and donate. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala bless and preserve
you guys. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well, inshallah. So, this was a
video that I came across, subhanallah,
of a Muslim
neighbor. There's some speculations that
apparently he was a
Sikh. Some are saying he's a Sikh. He's
faking to be a Muslim. But the true
story behind it is that he is a revert,
brother, from what we know. We haven't
verified it that he's a Sikh revert to
Islam who's living there with his
family. So, he's been getting this
abuse. And I'll be honest with you, this
is something I have experienced myself,
which I'll come to in a minute, because
um I used to live in a town called
Grimsby. I would say the most racist
town I've ever been in my life.
Happily been happily been called, you
know, casually the word P N uh etc. to
my black friends etc.
I can remember my house was attacked. I
was From what I'm saying, I was 12 years
old. They came and started smashing the
windows. Me and my mom and my brother
were in the house. Uh racism I've
suffered racism deeply. Uh subhanallah.
So, this reminds me back then. So, I
thought let's play the video, inshallah.
Let's see what is exactly going on. And
subhanallah, yeah, let's go. Right. So,
as you can see from that video,
we've had three people come to our door
and attack us because we've confronted
their children about coming over and
smashing our door in with shovels and
sticks.
When we go and talk to them rationally
or try and have a discussion, what
they'll do is they'll then turn up to
our door knowing that we're all alone
and we don't have anyone while I have a
newborn and my family in the house. And
essentially what they'll do they'll
they'll team up. They'll bring like four
or five people knowing we're
outnumbered. This shows the cowardice of
these people. Turn up to our doorstep
and try and cause problems.
Well, I'll tell you what. You may have
all of the people with you. You may have
your worldly possessions, but we have
one thing and that is our Lord and he
will not abandon us.
May Allah expose these people on the day
of judgment. May Allah expose these
people for their lies.
Seething
with hate. Well, they'll call us they'll
call us pedophiles. They'll say, "You're
a dirty Muslim." They'll just make
hideous hideous lies.
Interesting. I mean, it's rich coming
from them. Pedophiles. Those guys at the
door so looked more like that they they
fit the profile of a pedophile. Uh a
white man middle-aged man uh who are the
majority like I mean, let's be honest
with you. They look more like a
pedophile than they can. I mean, not
only that, um
pedophiles around the world going to
Australia, different countries, all
around the world in the Western world,
this is your disease. You guys have this
issue. This is your problem. This is
your way of life. This is your problem.
The way of life that you live is what
caused the degeneracy. Yes, having
Netflix of 12-year-old girls in hot
pants. This is your problem, my friend.
You guys are the real pedos in the West,
with all due respect. This This is
pedophilia issue is your issue. Not only
that, it's from the high echelons to the
ones at the bottom like these little uh
uh morons at the door. Okay. Uh anyways.
So, even like people like Trump, yes,
Epstein
Epstein Islands. You guys are number one
pedos, man, with all due respect. You
have a whole island for pedophilia to
rape white girls. Subhanallah. Okay.
Disgusting, vile. In Islam, you get
executed, capital punishment. Order
evident. We don't send them to hot beds,
hot food, uh um hot showers. Everything
is nice, you know, a hot room, you know.
No, not taxpayers' money, my friend.
Yes, they will be they will get the
capital punishment. So, it'll be
deterrent to all the rest. So, they look
more like pedophiles than anyone them
themselves. But let's carry on. As you
can see,
look look. Look at seething with hate.
You see what I mean? They don't want
They don't want to discuss. They can't
They can't have a discussion. They don't
want to have a discussion. They're just
seething, absolutely angry. Look at the
hate. Look at the hate they have for
Islam. Alhamdulilahi for Islam. In a
nutshell, you can see, subhanallah, that
the brother is humble, brave and and
sensible enough, because this can go
different ways as well. And he's uh such
like no one to come to his door and
escalate the situation, which he has
every right to to have people there
to defend his family. Uh if I'm there
and I've got a newborn and my wife
there, the man them are coming over. The
man them are
people are coming over, brother. Okay.
Not to do the same to them because
they're not our teachers. We're not
going to go there and threaten them and
scare them etc. No, that's not the way
we know. Allah tells in the Quran to
repel evil with that which is good. And
the one and you will see that the one
you have enmity with, you see
friendship. So, subhanallah, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us they are
not our teachers. Uh but they're
cowards. They they they operate, you
know, I've come across these kind of
traveling ones. Okay. They come there
etc. four or five of them. You give one
right hook to the other one, headbutt
the other one. The rest uh run away.
Okay. Uh from life experience um I've
seen when they would racist towards me
when I lived in uh Grimsby. You know, we
we got into altercations with these
individuals. And then they put respect.
Then afterwards they respect you and
they're buddies with you. They're all
good. So, some of them need that
legally. And that's just to defend
yourself, by the way. Because if you've
got someone there uh trying to threaten
you, so I don't want to call for
anything anything um um
that would um uh you know, get Excuse
me. Get anybody in trouble. So, here are
you can see, subhanallah, it's so
important. The salaf when it talks about
the right of the neighbors. In my
country, they say, "Don't buy a house,
buy a neighbor." Neighbors are very
important. In Islam, they have great
rights. So, as I can see, this brother,
he went there and tried to convey to
them, "Look, your children are causing
nuisance." And this is They know. They
know what they're doing. And this is not
a Muslim issue, because at the end of
the day, this this if this was a Sikh
family, they would do the same thing.
They're racist. I've lived amongst these
people. Yes, I'm not saying all, but
there's some lovely
white people I've lived with.
Alhamdulilahi, I've I've had close
relationships with. Subhanallah, that um
I celebrate Christmas and Easter with
them. Lovely people, man. I'll be honest
with you, there's some things I just
admire about them, subhanallah. But
there were those chavs on these people
etc. who don't know better. Uh you know,
whatever is the matter. So, it's going
to be you're a Sikh, whatever you are.
Don't think you're going to fit in and
be like, "Oh, we're the far right."
There was this clown is a Tommy
Robinson's uh flipping Humpty Dumpty uh
thinks he's a Sikh. And listen, my
friend, they're going to ship you out
next. Uh straight after we're gone,
they're going to be coming for you guys
next. Uh and not only that, there was a
Sikh woman that got raped by two of
these far rights thinking that she was a
Muslim. They're going to come for you,
my friend. Yeah. Okay. Regardless of or
they didn't think she was a Muslim for
that matter. So, you can see and we know
the attack that happened to our sister
who got run over, subhanallah. This is
growing in hatred. So, brothers
brothers, inshallah, uh tell your woman
folk, inshallah, to be careful,
inshallah, if you're doing with dealing
with woman folk who are, you know, who
listen and you know, these nifaqi
radical feminists like, "Boss, baby,
I'll do my You know, until somebody
pulls up and like, "Ah, where's my
husband? Where's my brother?" Oh, now
you need it now. Yeah, okay. So, we're
not talking about them. Alhamdulilahi,
please protect your woman folk. Yeah,
inshallah, because at the end of the
day, Allah has made you the leader. Yes.
Uh so, protect them, inshallah, at all
costs and tell them to go home early.
I've told my wife specifically as well
uh to be very vigilant and go home
early, inshallah. Don't be out too much
uh because we care about them. And even
if that was not the case because for
whatever other reasons, you know.
Subhanallah, yeah. So, I just wanted to
mention that and say, "Look,
subhanallah, the salaf will tell us the
Prophet said that the the the neighbors
were classed as 40 to the left, 40 to
the right, 40 in front of you, 40 behind
you." So much so the Prophet said the
Angel Gabriel came and told me about the
rights of the neighbors neighbors so
much that I thought he's going to come
down with wahy revelation that they can
inherit from you. The rights of a
neighbor is adhim. So, I want to give a
reminder to those who are watching,
Muslims. When is the last time you
checked up on your neighbor? When is the
last time you gave uh Eid food to your
neighbor? When is the last time your
elderly neighbor you went and did
shopping for them? When is the last time
you cut the grass for them? When is the
last time you washed their car?
This is da'wah.
Wallahi, this is da'wah. How is your
neighbors? If you were to go and ask
your neighbors what they think of you,
would they say good stuff? How many
Muslims violate the neighbors' rights?
In this scenario, it's the opposite way
around. I'm just talking in general just
to make a message out of this. How many
of your neighbors would say would they
say this person is a good person? This
person Let me tell you something. Da'wah
is not just what you talk. Believe me,
wallahi, da'wah the Prophet that Aisha
said was the walking, talking Quran.
Okay. Actions speak louder than words.
Look after your neighbors. They are like
a sign of Allah. You'll be questioned.
You'll be questioned. Read al-Adab
al-Mufrad by Imam Bukhari. Yes. Basic
etiquettes of neighbors as well. You
won't Let me tell you something, my
friend. The rights of the neighbors are
adhim. They will even come to you on the
day of judgment and say, "Why did you
not tell me about Islam?" And the first
reminder is for me as well. So, guys, I
would urge you guys, inshallah, please
to uh number one, if this brother needs
help,
we can come there and to the escalate
the situation in a civil manner. Get the
police involved, inshallah. Uh but we're
not going to let any of our Muslim
brother sister just be there and and be
exposed to this and we will do something
about it. So, brother, if you can
contact if there's anything we can do,
uh please do that, inshallah. All legal.
And I just wanted to share that with you
guys, subhanallah. May Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala protect him and his family.
Till next time. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. May Allah
grant us righteous neighbors in this
life and in the hereafter. Goodbye.